we've got more from aoc and i apologize
in advance but this is actually super
interesting she went on cnn this weekend
and uh dana bash
loved that name dana bash because
watching cnn it's like being bashed in
the head
dana bash asked her if she was going to
support biden in 2024 i just want to ask
about president biden he is saying he's
going to run again in 2024 will you
support him
you know if the president chooses to run
again in 2024 i mean first of all i'm
focused on winning this majority right
now
and preserving a majority this year in
2022 so we'll cross that bridge when we
get to it but
but i think if if the president has a
vision and that's something certainly
we're all willing to entertain and
examine when the time comes
that's not a yes
yeah you know i think we should
endorse when we get to it but i i
believe that the president has been
doing a very good job uh so far and um
you know should he run again i think
that
i you know i think it's it's
we'll take a look at it
for right now we need to focus on
winning a majority instead of a
presidential election
man one of the people that like examines
body language and everything would have
a field day with that the way she's
shaking her nose she's saying yes where
she laughs all of those things but
there's a few interesting things about
what happens right there now first off
remember when when they handed biden
when they made all the backdoor deals
and they handed by them the nomination
which is exactly what they did right
let's not pretend that was anything
other than that they all the competition
dropped out on super tuesday they
promised gayp at a job they they did all
of those things right it's just obvious
the machine wanted biden he was the the
easiest one that they could let in okay
so be it uh but when they did that what
the mainstream media and what what most
of my somewhat sane liberal friends or
what most centrists said was biden would
not be the crazy leftist that was the
whole idea of the biden campaign he's
not the socialist lunatic bernie he's
not a woe crazy person he's an old
democrat and things will get back to old
democrat ways it'll be sort of like a
bill clinton kind of thing you know he's
just joe biden he's sort of nothing but
it's nothing's better than the
socialists well biden has governed like
a far left lunatic now obviously biden
is not in charge who's in charge i'm not
quite sure i'm pretty sure it was barack
obama in the easter bunny outfit a
couple weeks ago
but
he has governed as a woke leftist he has
tried to destroy the economy inflation
gas prices disastrous withdrawal in
afghanistan we can go through all of the
things right you know all of the things
try to buy a couch see what happens i
tried to literally
i tried to buy a stool yesterday an
outdoor stool for a bar and i bought it
the same exact stool that i was buying
uh la that i bought last year was uh 79
it's now 139 dollars that tells you
everything anyway the biden thing's a
disaster but what aoc is saying there is
really what's she saying the subtext is
even though he's given us everything we
want basically yes he didn't get rid of
uh you know college he didn't blow away
college loans and all that kind of thing
but he's pretty much done everything as
a crazy leftist but he's not good enough
for us and i guarantee you mark my words
right now
one of you write this down but dave
rubin said it the thing that comes after
biden in the democrat party is going to
be so much worse because in some ways he
was the last line of of he was the last
line of relative sanity with these
people it hasn't acted as sanity but it
was the last moment that the democrats
would pretend to be sane the next thing
that comes after him which will be
pushed in by aoc when she stabs biden in
the back and all and they get rid of you
know even though pelosi's bananas left
us now and schumer these people who
weren't their whole careers like
completely insane when they stab all of
them then they will finally burst forth
and be what they are remember they
pretended to be democrat socialists for
years they don't even say that anymore
they say that they are socialists now
there is a major socialist movement in
this country and they have plenty of
blue check twitter accounts on our
capitalist twitter um but
it's interesting because she's basically
saying it she's saying in a weird way
what we know to be true which is that
they're going to destroy biden i don't
even know that biden is going to make it
right i mean they should have 25th
amendment him already the guy
cognitively obviously is not there we
all know all of these things